last week I had a sit-down with eric
holder on these issues we met with the
White House policy staff I've been
working with moveon org in the center
for american progress and i don't think
this is typical bipartisanship where you
split the difference on someone else's
bad idea this is a genuine coming
together on core values
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Matt kibbe he's
the president of Freedom Works and a
best-selling author of most recently
don't hurt people and don't take their
stuff over those are words to live by
it's a libertarian manifesto let's talk
about criminal justice reform right now
because this is something that is in
ways that libertarians love to talk
about it's it's blowing apart the old
left-right political spectrum and
traditional coalition's what's going on
there and how are you guys working to
reform criminal justice issues yeah I
think I think a great demonstration of
the old rules not applying any more look
at the co-sponsors of the smarter
Sentencing Act which which fixes deals
with mandatory minimums and other over
federalization of non-violent crimes and
it's guys like Ted Cruz and Mike Lee and
of course Rand Paul and Jeff Flake also
with Patrick Leahy and sheldon
whitehouse very radical progressive
Democrats and I don't think either side
has has come together in some sort of
compromise position they all agree that
there's an over criminalization of
American life they agree that the
federal government has overstepped its
bounds and and for well-meaning reasons
they were going to get tough on crime
but that the perversions as a result of
that are things that both parties now
agree need to be fixed so I mean we're
in an age of like you know supposedly
intractable gridlock and where partisan
differences are so harsh that
Republicans and Democrats don't even
speak to each other they don't even spit
on each other they hate each other so
much how are these groups you know kind
of tea party Republicans or libertarian
leaning Republicans and progressive
lefties why are they coming together now
well I think there's there's a strong
civil libertarian streak that sets
coming from the bottom up right now you
know Washington has analyzed this
problem for 20 years the papers have
been written the date has been crunched
and yet nothing happens what's different
is from the grassroots there's there's a
push to get Washington more out of these
types of issues and I think both parties
are responding to that but I think it
comes to from in his broader context
there was a time when Rand Paul was
talking about this stuff and people
thought he was a little bit nutty but he
was he was listening to the American
people instead of the Y
and experts and then I guess events like
Ferguson even if it's not about
sentencing problems but it kind of
raises these issues of justice criminal
justice reform yeah I think there's a
lot of a lot of reasons to be excited
what's what's weird about this from a
Freedom Works perspective you know last
week I had a sit-down with eric holder
on these issues we met with the White
House policy staff I've been working
with moveon org in the center for
american progress and i don't think this
is typical bipartisanship where you
split the difference on someone else's
bad idea this is a genuine coming
together on core values and then you're
guilty and these guys as well as you
know as Freedom Works and move on and
whatnot you're forcing the mainstream to
actually go where you guys already are
yeah and i think that's that's what's
different i mean from a Freedom Works
perspective we're getting the push from
from our constituents our activists they
want to do something taco or their other
talk a little bit about other areas
where these kinds of unconditional or
not unprecedented but you know odd new
coalition's are forming are there other
issues like this well I think the
overall trend is skepticism of
Washington and I see that some on social
issues like the definition of marriage
issues like faith-based initiatives
things where big government
conservatives ran the table during the
Bush administration there's a lot of
people of faith that are realizing that
Washington DC is not the place to solve
these problems that you know letting the
federal government into your marriage is
a lot like letting a vampire in the
house it is a bad idea you see it on
education this this this broad uprising
against common core standards washington
DC top down the smartest people in the
room dictating how things should be
doesn't work for families it doesn't
work communities work better well we
will leave it there matt kibbe president
of freedom works thanks so much for
talking to reason TV about criminal
justice reform thanks for reason TV i'm
nicholas p
you